[Music]
oh god every father to his toddler no
oh no
[Laughter]
just go out for a pack of cigarettes
what happened
where he's like finally my problems are
so that's one way to get into season
three who is that channel max just stage
max just you guys are brilliant well
done it looks like they they inflated
kroger's head a little bit yeah
i love youtube i love these animators
hire these people for lucasfilm you can
hire shabook hire these folks they're
clearly very talented with a that was a
great team
welcome back to new rock stars as we
strut off into the binary sunset from
the book of event we actually overlooked
quite a bit about our little frog
gobbler grogu specifically that he spoke
his first words and he knows a lot more
about the force than probably his master
or x-master luke skywalker also that he
and a jedi by the name of ezra bridger
might both have an interesting jedi
connection when it comes to animals so
what is this x
youngling's secrets what the foundling
bling
we made it work the foundling
this is the sound leaks wikileaks is our
weekly reaction to the latest and
greatest in star wars i'm eric voss
we're now in the dune sea when it comes
to star wars content considering uh
obi-wan kenobi is not coming until the
end of may but right now i am with the
uh best tuscan tribe member i can ever
imagine braving these deserts with tommy
beckham
[Music]
yeah uh thanks a lot uh kenobi for
really effing us on super bowl sunday by
not dropping a trailer doctor strange
did it right
moon knight did it right
tripping down rescue rangers dropped a
trailer this morning but you couldn't
give us even just a little slice to
spend three hours talking about on this
show today instead we're wandering
around
scarves tied around our head searching
for those melonie onions that have water
in them that we can crack open and drink
starving for content thirsting for
knowledge
uh tommy we're uh back where we belong
here in the blue dungeon uh we just
spent all of last weekend together in
chicago had a great time thanks again
wonderful came out to talia hall thanks
to
rooster teeth and their very normal
podcast tour and of course the wonderful
headliners of the face jam podcast it
was a delight uh geeking out about star
wars with you tommy
we got to meet chief palpatine that's
right
and his son griffin
i never knew
i didn't know
man like the the audience turned out
they were all just so wonderful
thank you all very much right flavor of
nerds that i i've known you've been out
there but just to meet some of you in
person was just yes thank you thank you
to uh all the the multiple of you that
bought me shots of malort and also
screw you screw you for the multiple of
you that bought me shots of the lord
because let me tell you the show was
great the after show was great the
morning the after show
was not great not great for old tea
well uh we have some more about star
wars that we want to dig into today we
got to talk about these new details we
we've now started to focus on with grogu
as well as the mystery fate of cad bane
when we might see the septuagenarian
duro next and time is literally running
out to get the latest obsession book
above a fat shirt over at
newrockstarsmerch.com they're going to
be shoving that back in the sarlacc pit
soon so grab one while supplies last
it's such a cool boba fett hunter design
it's one of my favorite designs we've
done here at new rockstars those folks
at epic hero have really outdone
themselves so uh while you're there
though at the shop check out their new
mephisto shirt designs because wearing
those is the best way to tell people
that you watch new rockstars is actually
without actually telling people you
watch new rockstars i really love that
word search design that they came up
with too
it's it's perfect it is perfect pay me
in shirts guys that's all i ever say
just just send a shirt send a couple
shirts my way every week and i'll i'll
do wikileaks for free now as a reminder
whenever you get our latest obsession
shirts you get to write in a custom
shout out that will appear at the bottom
of our after shows that week so this
week we had gabriel powers asking hey
eric do you think they'll ever put lord
that in the scene with a clone maybe in
ahsoka with captain rex you know i
actually really hope that rex will uh
will show up in ahsoka i i feel like
that would give tim ware morrison a
chance to show up again in one of these
other shows i don't know if boba fett
and rex will ever have like an
interesting reason to ever have a
conversation but who knows i i think
that's an interesting thought for sure
uh and what else do we see oh nico
asking if you had a mod what would you
get um i'd probably just get like uh a
completely new back i hunch i don't have
a good um like back i it's not my
backbone it's really just my back
muscles but either way just replace it
all and then uh bruce says follow jesus
he is the way uh well he's the way for
you and he's a way for a lot of great
people uh but you know what sometimes
mandalorian dogma can be the way for
others um but you know what it's your
right to say that bruce and we and we
appreciate you i've got a question for
you
did we hear grogu speak this season on
boba fett or am i crazy well both can be
true you can be crazy i can be crazy but
we can also hear this little puppet talk
uh because i think we did i think we did
let's let's actually uh roll the clip
from the finale episode where amando and
grogu reunite on the back of that
rickshaw roll the clip
amanda look who's here
what
yeah the sound mixers there totally
snuck in a little toddler grunt from
groku they recorded some toddler to do
the audio for grogu and that toddler
whether or not it is scripted definitely
said da da and we know it landed because
mando says what the way a parent would
when a kid would say dada and it recalls
the final shot of episode six in which
the audio description spells out that
grogu begins to open his mouth to reply
to luke skywalker about which choice to
make and i think based on his reunion
with mando his words to luke in that
moment were gonna be hey you [ __ ]
jedi i don't want no part of you you
piece of [ __ ] you
cult
you call nonsense uh
i'm not gonna drink a goddamn kool-aid
give me that shirt i want that shirt
paint me in shirts
that's what he's gonna say
you can see it on the tip of his tongue
but for real i think i think dada may
have been what grow goose said to luke
it looks like this kid chose a father
and luke you could imagine so moved by
grogu chosing a paternal connection over
her life a solitude could not help but
be moved by that he's like if only
fathers chose sons and sons chose
fathers sometimes right like if only
luke skywalker had taken that lesson
that family connection beats jedi
orthodoxy he might not have gotten into
that whole mess with ben solo but uh you
know oh well now there was a line from
episode six so we didn't talk enough
about when luke told ahsoka tano it's
more like he's remembering that i'm
actually teaching him anything it's a
fascinating line the more you think
about it it reminds me how for learning
learning certain skills it can feel like
remembering what you already knew even
though you were never actually
explaining these things at least that's
what my ucb improv 401 teachers told us
as they took 450 from each of us while
they slept through us just doing the
same boring scenes over and over again
money please
uh it's more about agreeing it's more
about agreement than anything i would
have loved to have seen more agreement
than that i drank too many shots at
birds last night but man the students
love me
but this all reminds us that grogu is
over 50 years old the age luke's father
would have been right now and five years
older than ahsoka even so groku already
had the ability to use the forest to
push and lift and choke in life or death
circumstances in early seasons of the
mandalorian ahsoka told us that many
masters trained him over the years
during order 66 the night his jedi
training ended at least at the temple
groga would have been 22 at that point
which is plenty of time for him to learn
all kinds of stuff it's also possible
that after order 66 some other jedi took
him in and continued his training some
jedi like we've speculated luminara
unduly was around for a few years after
that so grogu knows a lot more about the
force and we realize he might have been
able to speak before all these events
and the trauma of order 66
caused him to revert back to a more
infantile state uh i'm doing some uh
jedi armchair analysis i like what else
is of a child
i also was
that made me think is there a
possibility that somebody
used
uh like scrambled his brain as a defense
to keep him from being able to be
located by
by by stormtroopers like if they made
him forget that he was a jedi that made
him safer because if he's young and
impulsive and able to use the force he's
going to be an easy target to pick off
but if they make him completely forget
that he has all these abilities and in
effect turn him back into a baby they
can't speak and doesn't really know that
they can use the force and just kind of
sits in that bassinet the whole time
does that make him safer from the chance
of being assassinated or murdered uh by
the empire so is this is there a jedi
that perhaps took drastic measures to
save grog
that's an interesting theory i mean it's
a kind of a messed up step to take
because you gotta imagine in this case
this uh yoda species from birth nearly
started to be uh nurtured and brought up
in the jedi way so all of his memories
were jedi memories so to scramble those
i guess using the forces he pulled
hermione on her parents and harry potter
she just
coughed call from spiderman no way home
just wiping his poor kid's memory pretty
messed up but he could imagine some jedi
thinking this is the best way this is
the way this is the way
i don't know if it protects him better
because ultimately like if the kid looks
like yoda he's going to be a target no
matter where he goes yeah you're right
but if you remember the the egg was
closed right before they keep some of
that bassinet whatever keeps him in the
bassinet yeah i think that's an
interesting very dark theory but i could
see that being the case i'm a dark guy
you know my mind is a clouded
thunderstorm of sadness
now grogu's moment with the rancor might
have been the biggest implication we
should look at here because it reminds
us of the force-linked connection to
animals that ezra bridger showed in
rebels and ezra's fate remains unknown
rebels ended with the sokatano joining
sabine ran in a search for ezra
presumably we're going to see a live
action ezra in the ahsoka series
presumably we're going to see a live
action ezra in the ahsoka series uh and
ezra's path may have even crossed with
grogus at some point before mando found
the child that's one thing i love about
these star wars shows is they just keep
jumping around at different points in
history and it's very possible for
characters that we know to have just met
and crossed paths with characters we
wouldn't have expected that's how we got
ahsoka
in this uh connection with both grogu
and with luke skywalker asked me five
years ago i never would have expected
ahsoka to cross with luke skywalker but
right now here we are i wanted to just
ask your thoughts on on grogu speaking
you know and do we see this as a
possible maturation of grogu or a
restoration to what he might have been
before and uh do we think that his time
with luke skywalker that we got enough
time away from uh mando for it to feel
earned after the season two finale i
mean it's a hundred percent more
movement than we saw from him
in earlier in in either of the first two
seasons of mando i think that his timing
with luke though we didn't get a lot of
it on screen
it it was a period of luke kind of
restoring the skills that grogu had
and and also
and and helping him you know improve on
those skills and to me it was perfectly
fine you know the the the ending of of
mandalorian season two was ha was
heartbreaking
overseeing uh
you know not to be like snarky but like
you're you're watching man pedro
pascal's uh stunt man in in
hold a puppet and say goodbye to him and
you're like oh this is really sad and
then he takes his helmet off as pedro
obviously but it's like you know it's
heartbreaking but it's not like a real
life drama taking place in kansas this
is a space western opera like it's a you
know i'm okay if things move faster and
we get groggy back in the show as a star
wars fan i want grogu in my life so yeah
just the just the moment of him being
ripped away from mandel for for what
appeared to be the the the better path
for him or the safer path for him that
was heartbreaking enough for me that a
reunion couldn't come soon enough yeah
tommy i agree with you i you know i
think a lot of people remember that
season two finale mandalorian is when
mando said goodbye to grogu and yes we
did see that happen but i was just
personally so overwhelmed by luke
skywalker showing up and what that meant
for the future of of groku i didn't
really think about that meant saying
goodbye to mando as much even though
honestly that is totally what that was
about i assume naturally these two would
reunite in the future because they are
the core dramatic relationship of that
whole story right um so really all i
really needed is just to spend one
episode one hour with uh grogoo and
luke skywalker and it was satisfying for
me to have them back together again
absolutely i i don't i don't need to
spend more time with just uh din jaron
by himself we had an entire episode of
that too and i think structurally for
the big star wars universe overall this
was done
perfectly but it did require a sacrifice
of some narrative continuity and some
structural integrity right of the book
of boba fett seven episodes right
i also think though i do like what you
had said kind of altering you know
obviously our immediate reaction to
grogu returning to mandel was like oh he
spurned luke or he
like you know he luke is like sitting
there sulking or seeing i like the idea
more of luke like kind of like
recognizing the reality of the situation
and being kind of like at peace with it
and being like oh he wants to go back to
the person he considers his father and
he wants that relationship yes very very
good point tommy but before we continue
today's episode is sponsored by honey
manny really searching for coupon codes
is a thing of the past honey is a free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart honey supports
over 30 000 stores online from tech and
gaming sites to popular fashion brands
and even food delivery imagine you're
shopping on one of your favorite sites
and when you check out the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click apply coupons you wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
that can find for that site and if honey
finds a working coupon you will watch
those prices drop here at new rockstars
everyone is using honey producer brandon
saves a lot of money on food and
delivery and producer zach saved a bunch
of money on a hotel room reservation
recently honey has found its over 17
million members over two billion dollars
in savings so if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out it's literally free and installs in
a few seconds and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this podcast so get honey for free at
joinhoney.com wookie that's
joinhoney.comwookiewith1e and thanks to
babel for sponsoring this episode
there's a lot of good goals to set for
yourself this year at the top of my list
is learning a new language with babel
the language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions our editor
john is learning italian and our other
editor joshua's learning spanish they're
using the bite-sized language lessons in
a race to fluency and they are loving
how easy and fun babble is to use
babble's 15-minute lessons were created
by over 100 language experts their
teaching method has been scientifically
proven to be effective with babel you
can choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babel speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and your accent there are
so many ways to learn with babble in
addition to lessons you can access
podcasts games videos stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee start your new
language learning journey today with
babel right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babble.com and use the promo
code wookie that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com code wookie
w-o-o-k-i-e-e
babble language for life support for
wikileaks is also brought to you by our
friends at manscaped the leaders in mail
grooming their fourth generation
performance package absolutely changed
the grooming game along with their
refined body wash to round out your
hygiene routine join the 4 million men
worldwide who trust manscape for their
shower time routine by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code wookie if you
don't have a back to bath you can hop in
the next best thing to keep your body
fresh and clean is the manscaped refined
body wash it's one of the great items in
the performance package 4.0 along with
our lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold all your goodies the
manscaped lawn mower is not only famous
for their skin safe technology it's also
waterproof or on the ocean world of
kamino with no worries and we know those
smooth kaminoans love a trim in tidy
downstairs department get 20 off plus
free shipping with a code wookie at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code wookie at
manscape.com keep your balls trimmed
fresh and clean with manscaped uh now
tommy uh back to where the book above
that left the star wars universe cad
bane i think the most exciting uh cameo
of a new character that we hadn't seen
before in live action uh i love this guy
i don't think he's dead i think that
blinking indicator light tells us that
there's still a heart rate there uh no
one ever really dies as you said in our
after show last week where do you think
we may see cad bane next the easiest
thing to do would be to just go back in
time
you know like just just have him appear
in kenobi uh
but i would not be surprised if we do
get him in the ahsoka as a hot like in
the ahsoka show as a like hired gun
kind of mercenary character like you
know he's alive
they don't have anything like ahsoka has
no knowledge of him having a run-in with
boba fett but just more that allows that
character to kind of expand beyond just
being like the heavy that he was in book
of boba fett you know come in
shoot cobb vanth shoot the deputy that
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up sorry for
swearing uh but per like totally got
himself killed despite repeated warnings
of like hey this is what's gonna happen
he effed around and found out i guess as
we said but uh but yeah i would i
wouldn't be surprised to see ken bain
show up in ahsoka i think that the
establishment of that character as you
said they're not done with him you know
like he's coming back and he's coming
back strong yeah i i think so i think my
answer is ahsoka i think he's going to
show up as uh as a as a adversary and
ahsoka maybe just for an episode yeah i
definitely think we'll see him again i
think uh when you build a duro mask that
looks that good you don't just use it
for two episodes of the book of boba
fett they're gonna bring that thing back
wherever they can and that voice is so
good right the voice acting the the
stand-in acting was incredible yeah you
know everything that went into bringing
cad band to screen was just flawless
absolutely and i think obi-wan kenobi is
the most interesting uh title for him to
show up in because that would be the age
of the empire that's right around the
time he'd be working with boba fett just
to go right back there so we could see
their backstory their history together
just if it's just like one cold open one
scene to one of the other episodes about
something else i'm totally okay with
that secondly i think mandalorian season
three i think would be a good place for
him to show up in for whatever reason i
think ahsoka's just gonna be involved
with other stuff like the search for
thrawn uh i don't i don't know if cad
bane is uh the most necessary character
to show up there but who knows
wherever he shows up i'm okay with it uh
but i want to throw something out there
the acolyte so the acolyte is going to
take place before phantom menace yeah i
think it's going to take place old old
you know old years and that's cad bain's
an old guy he's in his 70s this is an
opportunity to show his youth show how
he got started as a as a scrappy bounty
hunter uh working for different
authorities whether it's the trade
federation uh or the hutts we could see
this guy teaming up with darth maul that
was part of his past like let's bring
maul back to live action yeah can we is
that crazy to suggest not for me we'll
leave it there for this episode of
wookie leaks but tommy and i are gonna
be back every week as we make this shift
to covering obi-wan kenobi hopefully
we'll get a trailer soon maybe by the
time you're watching this the trailer is
out and you're like why aren't they
covering it but we are going to be
answering whatever biggest star wars
questions you have between now and then
now don't forget to check out our many
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
follow tommy at tommy beck told follow
new rockstars subscribe to wikileaks
wherever you get your podcasts thank you
for watching and we'll say it this way
this is the waves
you